For all the women in those 20,
30, all.
It could never happen to me.
Not my husband. He's such a good husband.
He's such a good father. He's so successful.
Oh, my.
It could never happen. Not my husband.
Not my husband. Never.
No. This is where that thinking will fucking get you.
So it does not fucking matter.
You know in your gut
who your fucking husband is and what kind of man he is.
You know it. And if you don't know it,
you'll eventually find out.
And I'm sure it doesn't come as a shock.
In his book,
he's very clear that he's been a womanizer most of his life.
He's loved sleeping with minute women
and having his fucking fill of the rock star life.
So you can only lie to yourself for so long,
and then you get to a point
where you either have to wake the fuck up and see
and acknowledge what has always been there,
what you've been trying to pretend is not there,
or you just dig deeper and continue to lie to yourself further.
It's your life, it's your choice.
You do what you want. I'm just saying,
if in your gut, in your heart,
there's something in there that's like,
you know, this marriage or something,
this man, the something.
I would listen to that feeling
so you don't get stuck in these fucking positions.
Being one of the women on this side
trying to shout to The ladies in the back